i've been asked to implicitly
differentiate the equation tangent
of x over y
is equal to x plus y and i've done
several implicit differentiation videos
but this tends to be one of the biggest
sources of pain for first year calculus
students so i thought i would give at
least another example it never hurts to
see as many as possible so let's do this
one so to implicitly differentiate this
we just apply the derivative with
respect to x operator to both sides of
the equation the derivative with this
respect to x
the derivative of the left side with
respect to x is the same as the
derivative
of the right side
with respect to x
and the the right side is going to be
very straightforward but the left side
is a little bit tricky so let's do that
on the side over here
let me write the left hand side
a little bit differently let me and i'm
going to do a different color let me say
that a
is equal to the tangent
of b
and let me say that b
is equal to
x
over
y
then a is clearly the same thing i mean
if i just substituted b back in here a
this whole thing i could rewrite as just
a
so if we're taking the derivative of a
with respect to x that's what we want to
do right here right we're just trying to
figure out let me just take the
derivative of both sides of this this
would be the derivative
the derivative of a
with respect to x
is equal to the derivative of x with
respect to x well that's pretty
straightforward that's just 1
plus the derivative of y with respect to
x let me write it like this i'll write
the derivative operator the derivative
of y
with respect to x
that's all we did we just applied the
derivative operator to y and we don't
know what this thing is we're going to
solve for it but obviously i can't just
leave this here the derivative of a with
respect to x we need to solve for a and
a is just this thing right here right
a is tangent of b and b is just y over x
and the reason why i wrote it this way
is because i wanted to show you that
when you take the derivative of this it
just comes out of the out of the chain
rule it's not some type of new voodoo
magic that you haven't learned yet so
the derivative let me just write down
the chain rule right here
the derivative of a with respect to x
the derivative of a with respect to x is
equal to the derivative of a with
respect to b
times the derivative of b
with respect to x that's just the chain
rule and it's very easy to remember
because these do not the dbs cancel out
you're just left with the derivative of
a with respect to x if you just treated
these like regular fractions so what's
the derivative of a with respect to b
what's the derivative of a with respect
to b
well that's just
one over
cosine
squared of b
and if you don't have that memorized
it's actually not too hard to prove to
yourself if you just write this as
sine of b over cosine of b but this
tends to be one of the trig derivatives
that most people memorize i think i've
already made a video where i proved this
in some books they'll write this as
secant squared of b but we know that
secant squared is the same thing as 1
over cosine squared and i like to keep
it in kind of the fundamental
trig
functions as or trig ratios as opposed
to things like secant and cosecant and
then what's the derivative of b with
respect to x
let's
what's the derivative
of b with respect to x so this is pretty
interesting let me rewrite b actually
let me write b
is equal to x times y to the minus one
so the derivative of b with respect to x
we could do a little bit of chain rule
right here we could say let me write
this the derivative of b
with respect to x is equal to the
derivative of x
times y to the negative 1. so the
derivative of x is one
times y to the negative one
plus
the derivative of y
so let me just write this plus the
derivative
with respect to x of y to the minus one
times the first term times x
so this thing right here and clearly i
haven't completely simplified it yet i
still have to figure out what this thing
is here but i just simply applied the
product rule here derivative of the
first term derivative of x is 1 times
the second term plus the derivative of
the second term times the first term
that's all i did there so the derivative
of b with respect to x is just this
thing right there so it equals
let me do it in the yellow so it's times
this is i'll do the blue since i already
wrote it this is the blue derivative of
b with respect to x is y to the minus 1
or 1 over y
plus the derivative with respect to x
of
1 over y
times x
so let me write that down here so we
just figured out
or we're almost done figuring out what
the derivative of a with respect to x is
and we could throw that in there but
we're not done what's the derivative of
one over y with respect to x
well we just redo the chain rule again
we just do the chain rule let me and i
want to be very clear with this and i
know this might seem a little bit
cumbersome what i'm doing here but i
think it might make a little bit of
sense let me just set c
is equal to 1 over y
so the derivative of c
with respect to x just from the chain
rule is equal to the derivative of c
with respect to y
times the derivative of y
with respect to x what's the derivative
of c with respect to y
well this is the same thing as i could
rewrite this as y to the minus 1 so it's
minus
y
to the minus 2 power
that's what this thing is
this thing
is that right there
and i don't know what the derivative of
y with respect to x is that's what we're
trying to solve for so it's that times
the derivative of y with respect to x
that just comes out of the chain rule so
this thing right here this thing right
here this is exactly this is the
derivative of
this thing with respect to x which is
the same thing as derivative of c with
respect to x so i can write this little
piece right here
i can rewrite this little piece as
minus y to the minus 2
d y
d x
and then of course that there is times x
and then we had the plus
1 over y and all of that was times the 1
over
cosine
squared of b
so now we've simplified this a good bit
and i hope going into this chain rule
didn't confuse you because i really want
to hit the point home that all of these
implicit differentiation problems these
d y d x's just don't it's not some just
rule that you should memorize they come
out naturally from the chain rule so we
solved d a d x
that is equal to this expression right
here so let me write it it's equal to
1 over
1 over cosine
squared of
b well what's b i it's cos x over y
cosine squared of x over y
times
times all of the this stuff over here
all of this mess
one over y
plus or maybe i should say minus
minus if i just simplify this x over y
squared
x over y squared
times d y d x
times d y
d x
and then that is equal to the right hand
side it is equal to
one plus there's an equal sign there one
plus
d y
d x
and now all we have to do is solve for d
y d x so let me just review how we got
here and you could you know i went
through the chain rule at every step of
the way but once you get the hang of it
you can literally just go straight down
this way and the way you think about it
is the right hand side i think you get a
derivative of x is one derivative of y
with respect to x well that's just d y d
x
but the left hand side you take the
derivative of the whole thing with
respect to x over y
so that's just the derivative of tangent
is 1 over cosine squared so it's 1 over
cosine squared of x over y and you
multiply that times the derivative of x
over y
with respect to x and the derivative of
x over y with respect to x is the
derivative of and it gets complicated
that's why it's good to do it on the
side here but it's the derivative of x
which is 1 times 1 over y which is that
term
plus the derivative of 1 over y
with respect to x which is minus 1 over
y squared d y dx from the chain rule
times the x and that's why it was good
to do over the side so we don't make a
careless mistake but once you get used
to it you could actually do that in your
head and of course that equals the right
hand side so from here on out it's just
pure algebra just to solve for our d y d
x so a good place to start is to
multiply both sides of this equation
times cosine squared of x over y
and so obviously that'll turn into one
on this side and the left hand side will
be
1 over y
minus x over y squared
d y d x
d y
d x
is equal to
i have to multiply both sides equation
times this denominator right here is
equal to
cosine squared of x over y
plus
d y d x d y
d x
and now what can we do we can subtract
this cosine squared of x over y from
both sides of the equation
and we get
one over y
minus cosine squared of x over y all i
did is i subtracted this from both sides
of the equation so it's essentially i
moved it over to the left hand side and
what i'm trying to do is i'm going to
try to separate the non dydx terms from
the d y d x term so i want to bring this
d y d x term over to the right hand side
so let me add x over y squared d y d x
to both sides so then that is equal to
x
over y
and let me write that in the color that
i originally wrote wrote it in
a slightly different color so that is x
over y squared
write the d y d x in orange d y
d x and then you have this term plus
cosine
squared of x over y
d y d x
d y
d x
i think we're in the home stretch let's
factor this d y d x out from the right
hand side so this is equal to d y
d x
times
x
over y squared
plus
cosine squared of x over y
and that is equal to this thing over
here it's equal to 1 over y
minus cosine squared of x over y now to
solve for d y dx we just have to divide
both sides of this equation by this
expression right here and then what do
we get
we get if we just divide both sides by
that we get
1 over y minus cosine squared of x over
y
divided by this whole business right
there
x over y squared
plus cosine squared of x over y is equal
to
is equal to our
d y
dx and then we're done we just applied
the chain rule multiple times and we
were able to implicitly differentiate
tangent of y over x is equal to x plus y
and the hard part really the hard part
really is getting to this step right
here after this step it's literally just
pure algebra just to solve
for the d y d x's and then you get that
answer right there anyway hopefully you
found that useful